perfect song for activist Marley diet
she's an author a public speaker and the
youngest member of Forbes 30 under 30
this year and she's not even in high
school yet Wow slacker at the age of 10
Marley started a campaign called
hashtags 1,000 black girl books she was
frustrated she said because she hadn't
read books in school featuring black
main characters so she set out to
collect books featuring characters that
look like her well she succeeded
big-time more than ten times over
Marley received and donated more than
eleven thousand books remember she was
just trying to get one thousand at the
time
well she's now 13 she's got a new book
it's called Marley dies gets him done
and so can you by sharing her own
journey she hopes to encourage others to
become activists in Marley Diaz joins us
at the table welcome thank you I
remember we were all blown away remember
nor there anyone you were just a little
girl raising all these books and we
thought she's going places ava duvernay
the great director who's directing
wrinkle in time wrote this about you the
foreword she's a beautiful brew of
kindness confidence and curiosity thank
you I like that oh I got to meet her
through all the events I've done with
Elle and I got to be a kind of editor in
residence for them and I wanted to write
things that express the experiences of
girls and I had to I had an interview
with her and I was so lucky to get to
ask her questions like were her favorite
books as a teenager and who inspired her
and why she decided to be a director
even though she was a publicist
originally that's how she's sorry but
she nailed it about you she didn't say
you were a TBN which is a total book
nerd oh thank you I appreciate that
because you know I try to judge your
book I try to block out the words
because there's some words you know I
don't want people calling me completely
a total book nerd and in the book I talk
about it where yeah I'm kind of a
perfect mix of everything and so is
everybody else
so if you like reading you are allowed
to like to dance I do like to sing and
to like to act even though I wear
glasses I'm not just a mousy person who
stays in my room even though I do
sometimes yeah Stacy my Truman reads but
your campaign about racial harmony what
are what is it that you're seeing that's
disturbing you that you said I got to do
something the biggest thing that
disturbed me is these social structures
and these infrastructures in schools and
in our communities that are pushing away
from this intersectionality of being a
black person and a woman and a girl and
they're not including all of us but they
are thinking that because you're black
and because you're a woman we are trying
to create a system that supports you but
they're not thinking about that point of
intersection between the two where I I'm
a mix of both and that we need to
include me in both of those realities
and not just one or the other what about
your friends in terms of this racial
harmony though I have a very diverse
group of friends and I feel like in
school we try to just be open with each
other about whether or not we feel like
we made someone made a joke that was not
appropriate or we feel like we were
saying something that was not educated
response to a question which I know
makes us sound like you know we're
really like PC whatever doesn't really
like this but we have a lot of fun
together so at the same time we try to
keep it you know loose because not every
conversation is going to have perfect
knowledge with the things that we say
but we want to always stay educated on
the things that are happening in our
community and the communities that
surround us what are some of the things
and advice you give in terms of being an
activist I think the biggest thing is
success is not measured by a whether or
not you're on CBS this morning or
whether or not you make the local where
decision Marlee but I mean that it's not
measured by the the things that the
places that you go into realistic things
but by the actual people that you touch
in the place of your servicing so I'm
servicing black girls and I'm servicing
educators and all kids to see the beauty
and diversity of people but I want to
make sure that everyone knows that when
you help that one person or when you
give back your full energy you are
helping somebody just as much as I am
where does your confidence come from at
this stage you know I've because I'm
thinking she's got no notes no nothing
this is just you talking because you do
have a very confident way about you
where does it come from this desire to
improve be better and then spread this
message to others I think the biggest
thing where my my passionate miss comes
from is that I love reading and it is
something that I really care about and
it's not like I'm talking about football
or basketball or dancing things that I
enjoy but I'm not necessarily my
favorite things and I try to say with
kids you always even here in the middle
about things that you like pick with the
stuff that you know you can go on and go
on and keep going and keep going because
it's so much more important to continue
with that because you'll feel so much
more joy than the things that you do
yeah you said the most important thing
in the title
Marley gets it done and so can you with
you being the most important work yes I
feel like confidence is something that
ain't really important Thank You Marlene
and congratulations on this book it is
available online